une assemblée publique pour voter les
grandes décisions du conseil
départemental voilà comment peut- être
défini les séances plénières des élus
directeurs de services média
personnalités de la société civile
tous sont présents pour un ordre du jour
chargé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un discours d'action pour des
conseillers départementaux
mais dès que le journaliste interroge la
présidente c'est pour parler du glaive
donc quand on veut attaquer des ennemis
il ya mille façons de le faire
vous envoyez un truc sur un premier
raconteront l'histoire est banale et
fait reposer et c'est pour ça que le
soupçon ne doit pas donner à la 26
médiatique ou à la vindicte populaire le
travail des élus retour dans l'hémicycle
et au fonctionnement de cette
institution ou une commission éthique a
justement été créé pour suivre tous les
sujets qui concernent la collectivité la
meilleure façon de d'anticiper tout cela
de faire de la vraie communication
partager c'est bien de mettre en place
en seine même du département une
commission éthique qui permet à ceux qui
siègent en toute indépendance d'aller
voir ce qu'on fait dans tel secteur
d'aller demander à voir sur les emplois
mais aussi sur les politiques publiques
et donc c'est en venant de l'intérieur
en venant voir les pratiques qu'on aura
la bonne information en toute
transparence
le budget a été validé à la majorité des
élus mais une même problématique revient
me suis effectivement les problèmes
proviennent à savoir des problèmes de
fragilité de leur équilibre
notamment parce que l'état ne finance
pas suffisamment les dépenses d'aidé
sociale notamment les dépenses des
associations des bénéficiaires du rsa et
au département nous mettons 150 millions
sur le budget propre de la collectivité
pour financer des dépenses de
l'association des bénéficiaires du rsa
est l'une des solutions volontariste
résident dans les pays de la zone océan
indien
une thématique transversale comme
solution d'avenir nous allons mettre en
place les conditions d'une vraie
coopération
c'est à dire de faire rencontrer les
hommes et les femmes à travers les
politiques d'insertion de valorisation
économique de pratiques partagées ou de
savoir faire partager dans le domaine de
la culture dans le domaine sportif dans
le domaine économique et donc on fait
rencontrer ces savoirs autre point
abordé l'agriculture le développement
des os ou encore l'investissement sur
l'eau il s'agit d'une démarche tout à
fait innovante
initié par le département il s'agit d'un
plan pour améliorer l'accès à l'eau dans
les eaux
donc il s'agit pour nous d'abord de
faire un état des lieux de voir
les ressources existantes et de mettre
en place des outils pour améliorer
l'accès à l'eau dans les eaux
d'abord l'eau potable bien évidemment
puis l'eau agricole donc tout cela aura
une incidence évidente sur la vie des
réunionnais d eau en en matière de deux
beaux tableaux agricole d'agrotourisme
et puis un élément non négligeable c'est
surtout de pouvoir améliorer la défense
à 110 contre le feu de forêt trois
heures de débat qui donne les axes de
travail sur l'avenir de notre
département
[Musique]